prepare to be knighted and dive further
into the friendzone because we have the
latest episode of Game of Thrones and
take your own bloody pants off
oh my god joking aside this episode is
chock-full of new details so join me as
we break it down discuss your burning
questions and have a little fun along
the way and we get right into it with
Jaime Lannister seemingly on trial for
being the traitorous scum Sansa and
Daenerys make him out to be after all
Jaime is the Kingslayer having killed
Danny's father Aerys Targaryen the Mad
King and also was responsible for
bringing in Ned Stark who is later
executed Danny's brother Viserys who was
killed by molten gold by her husband
Khal Drogo warned her of the evils of
Jaime in the Lannisters
after all Cersei pledged to send an army
north and the only one to show up was
Jaime a point Tyrion uses to defend his
brother your grace I know my brother
like you knew your sister Jaime defends
himself saying this was a time of war he
would do anything to defend his family
which he truly believed to be the right
thing to do at the time and bran comes
in echoing Jaime's infamous line from
episode one the things we do for love
the things I do for love the question
then becomes why doesn't bran just tell
everyone about Jaime pushing him from
the tower all those years ago this plays
a pivotal role in understanding how the
next few episodes will play out but
we'll get to that in a bit then a moment
we've all been waiting for Brienne of
Tarth sticks up for sir Jaime putting
her neck on the line to defend the honor
and integrity of her secret man crush
come on guys if she ends up with tormund
we riot making an impassioned speech she
tells Sansa that if it weren't for Jaime
neither of them would be alive and Sansa
ends up making the decision for him to
stay a choice Danny isn't too keen on
she asked Jon what he thinks but John is
so conflicted from the revelation last
episode that he's the rightful heir to
the throne he spends most of the episode
avoiding her like the alpha male that he
is Dany is pissed is get Tyrion for him
having trusted Cersei especially since
she took his advice as hand of the Queen
she tells Varys and Surge aura that she
suspects one of them will be hand before
this is all over insinuating Tyrion will
be fired or dead before this season is
done we love Tyrion I
wouldn't bet on him losing his job
anytime soon lords and ladies we need to
talk about gentry an area cuz hot damn
these scenes are when aria isn't
checking him out she's wondering where
the hell are special weapon is from
episode 1 remember this cool thing with
the detachable part you bet your ass
this is gonna come into play later this
season whether it will be to kill Cersei
or the White Walkers yes it's made out
of dragonglass we've yet to know but
it'll likely play a big role in the
episodes to come then Aria shows off her
dagger skills turning on Gendry big-time
and look at this dude over here after
arias thrown like three daggers oh [ __ ]
I should get out of here now for the
scene we've all been waiting for
oh those cool new skates now you be
careful with those don't want to fall
break something oh that's funny that's
real funny let me give you a hand
Jaime starts by apologizing but Brad
knows Jaime was simply protecting his
family in fact if it weren't for Jaime
throwing him out the window the chain of
events that resulted in bran becoming
the three-eyed Raven never would have
happened
but the biggest revelation in the scene
is why bran didn't tell anyone about
Jaime pushing him out from the tower you
might be able to help us in this fight
to find that the muder you first yes
since Brant has seen the future he knows
Jamie plays an integral role in fending
off the White Walkers and when Jaime
says what about afterwards how do you
know that now this has a double meaning
one that everyone dies and there will be
nothing after the battle or two what I
think is more plausible is that he's
alluding that Jaime will die if not in
the Battle of Winterfell but before the
season is done
Jaime must fulfill this destiny bran
knows now whether this is killing Cersei
or the night king making him once again
a Kingslayer we have yet to find out but
I think we can all agree he at least
needs to get it on with Brienne before
he meets his end in a heartfelt scene
between the Lannister Bros Tyrion
reveals he underestimated Cersei and
should have never trusted that her new
pregnancy would change her even asking
Jaime if it's true is she actually
pregnant Jaime says yes but hold on a
minute is that Cersei drinking wine
while pregnant last episode
Shayne yes my theory is that she isn't
pregnant at all and she's using it to
manipulate the men in her life and back
on the wall Jamie seems to only have
eyes for Brienne notice all the bits of
dragonglass they've set along the
ramparts in preparation for the coming
invasion
Podrick sword skills are getting as good
as his singing Jamie tries to pick up
Brienne and she ain't havin it we have
never had a conversation last this long
without you insulting me not once you
wanted to insult you no good he's a
changed man Brienne he just wants to
fight alongside you captain friendzone a
cage or Mormont appeals to Dani on
Tyrians behalf telling her that Tyrion
is an honorable man
but he also suggests she should have a
chat with Sansa who's wearing what the
hell did I not get an invitation to the
Winterfell BDSM party and Sansa also
vouches for her ex-husband Tyrion to
which Danny says he never should have
trusted sassy you never should have
either awkward then Sansa drops the line
that families are complicated no [ __ ]
Danny is boning her nephew and after she
tells Sansa her whole life has been
nothing but the pursuit of the iron
throne wait till she finds out her lover
is the rightful heir
she tells Sansa the only other man she's
trusted in her life was a lot taller
of course she's talking about Aquaman
but before they can discuss who will
eventually take over the north they're
interrupted by Westeros his favorite
eunuch Theon Greyjoy he has come to make
amends with the Starks especially after
all that [ __ ] he's caused them and Sansa
seems to be forgiving a whole video
could be done on the history of Theon
and Sansa sural a ship but for the sake
of keeping this video short this
poignant seam seems to show that Sansa
has forgiven him here are some children
eating Arby's Davos seer quells the
fears of local civilians who are being
armed for the fight remember Davos isn't
a fighter either but he himself survived
the Battle of the bastards if he can do
it so can others then Gilly appears
telling the old people and children to
settle down in the crypts
but honestly is that the safest place to
be the night king can raise the dead
does this mean we could potentially see
old Starks skeletons rising from the
crypts just throwing it out there guys
then this girl's like
and Davos has taken aback because this
young girl reminds him of Shireen
Baratheon Stannis Baratheon's daughter
who was too hot to handle the burn marks
on her face reminiscent of Shireen's
greyscale and can we all just take a
moment to remember how Shireen taught
Davos how to read haha then a blow horn
signals the arrival of Edison
tormund and beric Dondarrion who he saw
last episode examining the mysterious
symbol the night King left at last
hearth they made it just in time before
the White Walkers are to attack which
torment says they'll be here before the
Sun rises tomorrow but really he has one
thing on his mind
the big woman still head
then we have John snow warning us of the
impending invasion how they're amassing
heaps of dragonglass and one of the
things I love best about this montage is
how they show Dothraki unsullied and
wildlings in the same shot three
completely different peoples from
different walks of life banding together
united to stop a common enemy brings a
tear to my frozen heart now take a
moment here to look how outnumbered they
are on this map it looks at least five
to one and John even says they can't
beat them in a straight-out fight they
need a plan and that plan involves
defeating the night king they kill him
boom Wars over and how can they get at
him by using bran as bait bran says the
night King has come many times for many
three-eyed Ravens hinting that this war
has been won over countless centuries
the night King won't stop until there is
an endless night bran also has the mark
of the night king which if you'll
remember from season six was given to
him when he stayed too long in the
three-eyed Ravens vision a vision which
eventually led the night King to kill
the old three-eyed Raven but was
unsuccessful in doing it fully since the
three-eyed raven transferred his powers
to the new host bran this mark acts as a
tracking device
leading the night king in his army -
bran they can thus use bran to lure the
night king Theon offers to protect bran
as significant reversal since seasons
ago Theon took Winterfell from the
Starks now he's here to defend them but
the big question is whether Danny's
dragons will be able to stop the
oncoming horde and for once bran doesn't
seem to have an answer he says no one
has ever tried dragon fire against the
White Walkers we might just be able to
find that out next episode the Sendai
tries to make friends with some children
of the north but is rejected that's
racist
this is all a preamble to grey worm
asking her what she wants to do when
this is all over they talk about moving
back south to the beaches and how he'll
swear himself to protect her but all I
can think about is how this foreshadows
gray worms death probably in some heroic
feat protecting the sand aye so let's
keep an eye out for that and look Sam
and Jon on a wall just like the good old
days Sam wants to fight up top with the
real men reminding Edison and Jon that
he was the first one to kill a white
Walker and his bad ass is stolen a
considerable amount of
books well if that's what it's come to
be really awful tieran remarks on how
ironic it is two Lannister's are now
defending Winterfell but their party is
cut short move the puns are bad by
Brienne and Podrick and my man Tyrion
pouring a full-ask glass of wine then in
here two shots of vodka Davos and
torment are soon to join with torment
giving us some weird story about giant
titty sucking which only reminds me of
now yes this is more of a comic relief
scene but it also acts as a significant
sign that tormund will not end up with
Brienne and that Jaime is her OTL now
this scene with the Hound wasn't really
necessary but it was good to check up on
him right before the impending battle my
prediction is that the Hound will make
it out of the Battle of Winterfell a lot
since we have yet to see cleganebowl the
Hound versus the mountain now there is
nothing that turns on a girl more than a
custom spear and she is grilling Gendry
about his love life more than my
father-in-law about mine but hey her
charm seems to be working with the worst
pick-up line in history we're probably
going to die soon I ought to know what
it's like for that yes my results using
that weren't as effective Gendry and
Arya get it on and what is obviously a
hot pie wet dream Tyrion offers a
glimmer of hope saying that they might
actually live through this and the irony
isn't lost on him that almost everyone
in this room used to fight against the
Starks and get out your tissues ladies
and gentlemen we have a knighting
ceremony tonight and Jamie is the one
tonight Brienne I promised myself I
wouldn't cry Jorah tries to persuade
Leanne and not to fight she's the future
of the Mormont house after all but she
refuses for those wondering they are
both cousins even though this crazy age
difference also noticed the Warriors in
the background carrying the sigil of
house Arryn on their shields which we
haven't seen in some time
John Aaron's death was the event which
sparked the entire game of Thrones story
sending Eddard to King's Landing and the
subsequent events that followed Sam
gives his family sword hearts pain to
Jorah a sword made of Valyrian steel
held in the Tarly family for centuries
but since Sam can't even hold the darn
thing up he feels that a fitting gifts
in
Jorah was the son of the old Nightwatch
commander who taught Sam how to be a man
then Podrick sings a song on the eve of
the giant battle played over a montage
of our characters and to me it was just
like that scene in Titanic where the
orchestra is playing and everyone is
succumbing to the reality of their
situation hot in the crips Danny asked
John wTF is up and he lets the direwolf
out of the bag by telling her he's the
son of Lyanna stark and rhaegar
targaryen making him the rightful heir
of the Seven Kingdoms and her nephew now
remember in her scene with Sansa she
told her the only thing she's held on
all these years is claiming the Iron
Throne with this new bombshell she
doesn't seem to be taking it too well
even questioning its validity but before
they can work it all out the battle
horns blare the Battle of Winterfell is
upon us and one thing I found a little
curious is why they didn't end the
episode on the night King to me it seems
like it would be the logical choice to
end on him
but not showing him raises a lot of
questions is he even there is he riding
on the dragon we'll find out next
episode which the showrunners claim is
the longest continuous action scene ever
put to film I am pumped and I hope
you'll join me and as always if you like
the breakdown make sure to LIKE
subscribe and share I'll be doing one
every episode so hang on tight and
remember daddy loves you very much
[Music]